[Music]
uh hi everybody welcome back
our next speaker is danielle navarro
hi so yes i am danielle navarro
um i'm a psychologist uh at the
university of new south wales
and i'm going to talk today about
a project that i've been doing on
building an art package that'll let you
write behavioral experiments in r
and it's not the sort of thing that
maybe huge chunks of the r
user community need but i'm going to
explain why it's really important
to a subset of users and how it really
matters a lot in my work
so i should start by saying something
about who i am um so
this is me uh i have like a website and
everything like everybody does
and really the reason that most people
pay any attention to me is
side projects very much like france is
talking about most of mine involve art
and i usually do a whole bunch of
generative artwork with
r but in my spare time i try to act as
an academic and so i do
extremely boring things like write
academic papers
but in between doing that i sneak in
some r packages which
it gives me something useful to do with
my time but all of that and kind of
reinforcing in some ways ryan's message
in his talk
is that playing around with these things
taught me a whole lot of useful stuff
and it got me to the point where i was
able to start
writing a textbook so i taught her i
wrote a
introductory statistics textbook pitched
it
undergraduate psychology students not
typically the people most
interested in this kind of stuff and it
was reasonably successful to the point
where like i released it under a
creative commons license and
it got translated into other programming
languages and apparently now
it's being translated into other actual
languages like french and japanese and
somebody's doing a spanish one and
it's very exciting and i don't know why
everyone likes it this much but i'm very
happy
okay that wasn't just bragging it also
brings me to
sort of the point right the thing that i
want to talk about writing
is there it is okay is a package that'll
allow my students and my
collaborators to be able to write
flexible behavioral experiments in the r
programming language and to put it in
some context
this is how behavioral experiments were
typically done in the early 20th century
so you have a machine like the one shown
on the right a skinner box
and we would have a subject who is
typically a rat
and they would be shown stimuli which
might be lights or sound or something
and so they're delivered by some
mechanism
and then they're rewarded with food
punished with
um you know by electric shocks and
things like that i'm not claiming
psychologists to good people
in fact i might go so fast to say we're
probably really bad people
but this is the structure of how things
used to be done and in many places still
is but it's much more common these days
in the early 21st century
that the machinery that we're using is
either a laptop if you're doing it
if you're running something locally or
you might be running experiments over
the web
which is now extremely common in
psychology to the point that it's
causing problems
but that then means that your
experimental design
looks kind of like the code that i've
got written there
on the left and in this case this is
something from one of my
uh my own experiments and it's written
in javascript and
uh i hated it um the experiment
actually the experiment itself worked
fine it was really nice psychology
it's terrible javascript because i'm not
a great javascript programmer
and i hate javascript i hate it
i mean i understand i
i understand why people like it what
it's useful for but i hate it
and more to the point i want to my
students and a lot of my colleagues hate
it
because it forces them to learn another
programming language at a time that they
don't want to
so think about this from this
perspective of the kinds of people i
work with most of the time
and to them this is how r looks like
they could walk into my office and say
okay
danielle i've heard really good things
about r explain to me
why i should invest the time and it's
really really easy to make the case that
r is brilliant for statistical data
analysis it's great for data
visualization data wrangling
general programming and they get excited
they are really really keen on
putting the effort in and every single
time the next question
is can i write my experiments in this
because psychology being an experimental
science is deeply reliant on the ability
to do this
and this is where i start crying and my
students
tell me that i'm out of here right they
are not
pleased to discover that they're going
to have to learn javascript to do that
job
so what are other languages do to deal
with this problem well
python has a framework dealing with it's
psychopi
matlab has framework the site toolbox
that a lot of people use
r doesn't have any clear analogs to this
at the moment
and a lot of people don't want to switch
from matlab uh
to r because of it or when they're
thinking of making a switch they will
move to python instead
and i genuinely do love python so i
don't feel sad about that
um but i also think that r is a great
thing for a whole lot of purposes so
can we do something this way so that's
my goal how am i going to solve this
problem
my first idea is i'm going to do it
natively in r
right i mean why not there's if i have
if i've got a system that has
uh allows me to open up an x11 graphics
device like this is interactive it will
respond to keyboard
presses and mouse clicks and things like
that so this is a really simple
psychology experiment you show people
these visual arrays and your task in
this case would be
judge whether there are more triangles
pointing up or pointing down
and there are models of this like quite
complicated models that go back
decades and people care about low-level
features in this data they care
about it a lot and this is a problem
so okay the plus side before i
complain is that it's actually really
easy to write these experiments right
you just have to um learn one or two new
commands and they're sitting right there
like get graphics event once you know
that you can do quite a bit okay
so it's surprisingly easy to code there
are a few dependencies
but it does have some problems you can't
do it online easily
the interactivity is limited i can't get
my participants
to type in a paragraph of text
occasionally psychologists have this
wacky idea of asking people
why did you do that and this is really
common when you go i don't understand my
results i'm going to
replicate the experiment and then i'm
going to ask people to explain to me
what i did wrong
so i need that and that's missing and
ultimately this is not really what r is
built for and as a general philosophy i
feel like
working against your programming
language is always a bad idea
okay so something that we do like hold
on
shiny everyone loves shiny i love shiny
this is a the very first attempt i
had to make a psychology experiment
within shiny and so this would be a
belief elicitation task sometimes you
ask people to give in
interval estimates so i've got to say
give a range of plausible values you
know an analog of a confidence interval
here
um for people to judge various in this
case nonsense propositions right and so
i click my submit button
and then refreshes gives me a new trial
and so on and
okay i can do this this is a reasonable
thing for shiny
though notice you know this is a real
app that's running in the background
here
and it's running on shinyapps.i o and
you'll notice it took
quite a while to set up right because
i'm not doing anything fancy to make
this thing scale
in order to build it here is the brief
tutorial that i wrote for my students
hold on no no
hold up hold on um ah
okay okay okay now we're getting to
fluid page
oh my god it's having data oh and then
at the end you've got
something where you ask people to judge
how strong correlation is
and my students are gone like
i can't even scroll down to the bottom
of the page in a time for the students
to be willing to do it not a single one
of my students has done this because
shiny as magnificent as it is has this
learning curve
so okay shiny it works online it's got
very flexible interactivity which we
need for behavioral experiments
but it has these shortcomings it's hard
for novices and if you've got a novice
and you have to hit them and they want
to run their experiment
online on a tool like say amazon
mechanical turk
they need their app to scale to not very
large scales but still
moderately large like we're talking
hundreds of concurrent users
and i do not want my undergraduate
psychology students trying to do that
so there's a whole bunch of other little
complaints that psychologists would be
yelling out about high precision timing
and all that kind of stuff but
i think you can kind of see why there
are some limits to shiny
so here's my approach to dealing with
that i'm going to give you the gist of
how i do it
here's what i want it has to be written
in our code because i am not trying to
teach
two programming languages to psychology
undergraduates simultaneously
it needs to be relatively easy to for
novices to learn
it the experiments need to be
browser-based because that's where most
of the stuff
is these days in psychology so because
we're going to care about
high-precision timing a lot of the
computation needs to be put client-side
so it has to be done with client-side
javascript
you need proper randomization flow
control programming constructs the sort
of things that we would hope to have in
any programming language of course
um and needs to support rich
experimental design so richer than
surveys
we're not just doing surveys here okay
so
i found like a friend of mine has
actually written a javascript library
that does
almost everything i want it has only one
problem
it's javascript okay so
i'm crying again because of javascript
so what i've ended up doing is starting
this is a work in progress but i'm
basically writing a package called
jsi short for j psi r see
psychology yeah i'm funny um so you code
in
r the experiment then builds
uh to js psych so it will compile it
will write
all of your javascript files for you and
there's a very very thin
r server at the back end that doesn't do
very much but it's
constructed using plumber that will
handle back-end stuff when you need it
and then when you want to run the
experiment you can either deploy it
locally running it on your own laptop
or you can push it to google app engine
or whatever your favorite
cloud service is like i use app engine
so that's
that's where i've started so far this is
the sort of functionality we've got
so here is a super brief illustration of
the sorts of things you can do with the
package it's not going to be a tutorial
in
doing it i'm not going to explain code
in a ton of detail other than to
sort of illustrate that it's not
spectacularly complicated
so load the package okay experiments in
psychology will typically begin with an
instruction
set so you've got text here that can be
navigated
you will then specify some trials so the
trial here
might display in this case some html and
it's just going to
print out some text i'm doing the
dumbest thing i possibly can
participants have to respond with a
button and they're just going to
evaluate
whether an equation is true or false and
then
you build the experiment using a
function called build experiment and
that's the entire code
right there for a functioning experiment
and here it is it's currently
running on a github pages site notice it
loads immediately which is nice
so you can sort of go back and forth
like instruction sets need to be
navigable and all of that kind of stuff
and now we begin the experiment i don't
know is 13
23 36 sure why not i'm
a participant so i'm not paying any
attention anymore so i'm just pushing
buttons at random
um and all of this stuff is up on the
github page so
you can actually go and browse all of
these stuff and stuff over there
generally of course we want richer
things so there's ways of including
different kinds of media files so we'll
support resource files of various
different kinds
of images audio files or
video that kind of thing so you might
show
people a picture of some generative art
and uh get them to rate whether or not
they like it and we'll say no i hate
that one sorry
um or you could get them you know this
was me teaching myself gg animate and
playing around with it and
do we like that one okay that's pleasant
um
and then this you know we'll also do you
probably can't hear it but this is
playing sound so
yeah and i'll say that that's pleasant
and then ask it to shut up
so you can do that you can change the
response method
and the api is fairly consistent for
that so hey if you want people to
respond with the keyboard
the command says keyboard if you want
them to respond with a slider bar
it says slider this is supposed to be
fairly straightforward and easy
for novices to get to use right so again
there's a demo of it but i'm just going
to skip
it because it's exactly as interesting
as you'd expect
you can write survey pages so if you
need something richer where people
actually respond
to surveys things then you've got some
mechanics for that
um and so you can do things like oh okay
so i'll
say that do i consider myself to be
lgbtq
sure i'll click on that um you can have
things where you'll choose as many as
apply
so if i want deployer and per
whatever and you can fill out like at
scale surveys as well which are
extremely common in psychology so you
need people to rate things like that
and that's all being done within again
the same framework
at the back end then when everything
gets written it's just a plain csv file
nothing fancy
so that means that i my students when i
teach them d player can do that
they will be able to read this in and it
will fit in with the existing teaching
framework and the learning framework for
them
or you know if you need it it'll deploy
to google app engine and write stuff to
the data store there but i'm not going
to talk about that
um i will very briefly point out um that
it does allow proper
flow control and programming constructs
so there are ways of basically saying
that well suppose
if my first question had been uh do you
identify as lgbt iq and i click no
i really shouldn't have a follow-up
question that asks you to specify
exactly which category you belong to so
there's some logic in there for
modifying i'll just highlight the one
bit that actually matters
there's a sort of timeline display if so
as long as a particular condition is met
then that that trial will be displayed
or that block of trials will be
displayed
if it's not then it doesn't show so
you've got your if statements
there's a similar logic that will let
you do looped execution with a command
called oddly enough
tl display while so it's got the
equivalent of a while loop
right and so you can do things like this
and say okay well i prefer not to answer
this question so i wasn't offered a
follow-up
um and i can do stuff like force people
to like my art
so oh it's unpleasant okay neutral oh
it's unpleasant
fine there we go okay so
that's what it does and before i start
complaining about my own work
i will say that in and of itself this
has been really helpful
because a whole lot of my students can
build a remarkably
rich range of experiments just with that
but i'm still annoyed and so the things
firstly they've got all the usual
complaints
the whole thing's work in progress so
it's janky okay
like that's part of the reason it's a
work in progress
but there's a deeper issue here which
has to do with the flexibility of
behavioral experiments
here is a subset of the different trial
types supported it's fairly long and
if you look at it on some of the pages
you start getting worried because this
is a very very small subset of the
things a psychologist might want to use
and the problem ultimately is trials
this is
whole events where you show something
make a person do something respond
to them are not primitive objects right
and so when you look at what
the js psych library itself you get this
massive proliferation of experiment
specific plugins that are all written
in javascript and they do have a plug-in
framework which means you can do this
but honestly if you're not a linguist
you don't want closed trials
if you're not a social psychologist you
don't want implicit association tests if
you're not
interested in perception of monkeys then
you're not really that interested in
random.motion tasks
and honestly unless you are richard
aslan specifically you do not
need a visual statistical learning
animate occlusion trial or
a visual statistical learning grid scene
trial
i am not going to write plugins for
every single one of those things
no it's not going to happen so
this is a a problem that needs to be
overcome so the direction i'm planning
on heading with all of this is actually
to look at decomposing trials into
smaller parts
right and so that you can build at build
time
have it construct the task specific um
plug-in that you need and so the logic
is something similar to
things that we talk about in the r
community a lot right we know this stuff
from things
like the grammar of graphics you don't
think of plots as primitive objects
instead you think of them as composed
of parts and those parts are reusable so
you've got your data your aesthetics
layers scales coordinates themes and
each of those things can be specified
individually so that the range of plots
that ggplot2 can support is much broader
than the you know it's much wider than
the number of actual functions in the
package
so this is this open question that i'm
working on at the moment is thinking
about what does the logic of that look
like for psychological experiments
and that's where things start becoming
messy right i mean i'm not going to go
into details and this is probably not
the sort of room where everybody cares
about it but these sorts of images
are grossly typical in the psychological
literature
and this is simply displaying a stimulus
like this is one thing that is shown to
a person over time so
your core element is some kind of space
your temporal object
at its its base and that's only one part
of what a trial might be
so you've got something like primitive
elements which might be
images audio or snippets of html
those things can be composed together
into stimuli in some fashion so you need
a set of rules for combining those
but you also need a similar kind of
logic that will handle the responses and
so
exactly what method will the human use
to respond so in our
traditional skinner boxes that was
things like the wrap
presses a bar um but humans are slightly
more complicated than rats
and so we tend to have things like text
boxes and html button presses and we can
move mouse
the mouse around and you could support
all sorts of other devices if you really
wanted to
and so on and so forth so at the moment
where i am at is
actually thinking about what that
decomposition looks like and what kind
of future package i'm going to build
over the top of it
in order to support the full range of
experiments
that my users require
but right now though despite these
limitations and grumbles
the package that i have solves a problem
that a lot of my
my colleagues my students and my friends
have and so that makes me pretty happy
so i'll leave it at that
okay looks like we have one question
about your artwork danielle
do you have any advice for how to get
started with a generative art and
i do actually um so i mean the first one
is
have fun play like a huge part of it is
a little bit like
everything that ryan said go do
fun stuff but the other you know besides
that sort of generic
uh going playing around i actually um
so i should be able to find out my
website if i just scroll right back to
the beginning
[Music]
okay so if i go over here under the blog
part
i actually wrote a little is it going to
let me do this
oh i have to bring this back up again
just a moment
and i actually because i write
random things from time to time that
people are find interesting
i actually wrote a little blog post that
covers exactly this
so the point of the post here is
actually just to talk about the pro like
this was me on the fly
building a new generative art system
and so it was kind of tracking some
successes and failures
and how to actually build something that
eventually generated me some interesting
images like that
and that so almost everything that i
would say as my advice for getting
started is have a
like i already wrote it down um so you
can go and read that
uh and it also has sort of hints about
what you do to get started and start
playing with these things
but playing is pretty much the key thing
playing around
and making a lot of screw-ups
all right thank you we're going to let
our next speaker get set up
you